I want my you doing still share for my
little boy everybody I'm not so bad got
some energy back off that juicy crab or
a animal don't look now I think
someone's up there
here we are today on Margaret's Harbor
arm where the term stones have just
returned from their long flight from
Canada over to lr who's with the term
stones now lately they've been mean
disturbances with the birds in form of
the general public getting too close to
the birds lifts are invading their roost
sites dog walkers allowing their dogs to
walk amongst roosting birds let's go
back to Tunisia who's with the dog
walker here we have Becky who walks her
dog carrier nearly every day on Margate
beach let's see what she thinks about
letting her dog loose near the birds I
never really realized it was an issue I
let her loose every day what's the
problem with it well if you let her
loose every day then the birds are more
likely to fly away because they're
scared and it uses up their energy early
on and what do they need their energy
for they need it to fly to canada well I
never really realized that I should them
take more respect of the beds on the
beach thank you very much for your time
now back over to you Ella now if we look
here the amount of rubbish is posing a
big threat to the birds not only do they
risk getting trapped in the litter they
could also eat the rubbish which they
could choke or be poisoned on the litter
also damages their food supply back over
to Tunisia on the harbor all due to the
fact that these birds return to the same
Bay every year we need to make sure we
look after their homes
yeah that's what we want yeah something
actually killed mountains for change
thanks guys and you can go now no really
you can go look no really all right
everyone going and we will kill them
you